so the last thing is is is the the real
driver I think is actually this idea of
a cent or which came out of garry
kasparov the IBM chess champion who lost
I mean the chess champion who lost to
IBM deep blue and he complained about
the fact that deep blue had access to a
complete database of every single chess
move ever made and he said if I had
access to the same database
I could have beat deep blue so he made
up a new chess league that kind of a
free style where you could play as a
human an AI or a cent or AI plus human
and for the last three or four years the
best chess player in the world is not an
AI and it's not a human chess master
it's a center it's a team of AI plus
human and that's true for the best
diagonally diagnostic it's not a a AI
and it's not a doctor it's a doctor plus
AI and so that idea of working with
machines of having them complement our
type of thinking with their type of
thinking is actually where we're going
so I believe that you'll be paid in the
future by how well you work with these
AIS okay so so they're not we're not
working against them we're gonna be
working with them because they think
differently and if you can actually if
you can be the horse whisperer you can
be the AI Whisperer and understand then
you have an advantage in terms of being
able to to be the best in your class
you
[Music]